the new satirical comedy it's called
sorry to bother you is being hailed as
one of the summer's big hits by movie
critics it debuted this year's Sundance
Film Festival and it was a huge hit
critics call it bole fascinating and
unapologetically brilliant the movie is
a breakout directorial debut of musician
boots Riley it tells the story of
Cassius green he's an Oakland man who
quickly learns how to climb the
corporate ladder at a telemarketing firm
you want to make some money here didn't
read the script with the white boys when
people say I talk with a white voice
anyway so why did it open yeah well you
don't talk wait enough I'm never talking
about Will Smith wife I'm talking about
the real deal like this young hey mr.
Kramer
this is Langston from regal view I
didn't catch you at the wrong time did I
the New York Times says quote the film
is visually ingenious and funny yet
grounded by pointed arguments about the
obstacles to black success in America
writer and director boots Riley joins us
now at the table welcome and
congratulations hey accolades you were
getting boots must be really fun to hear
for you yeah I mean it's always if you
make a piece of art and then people are
talking about it and shouting about it
and laughing or whatever you know
mission accomplished I had to watch it
twice because the first time I'm
watching I was thinking what the hell am
i watching is I'm looking at it
especially the whole white voice thing
because I've been accused of white voice
my whole life okay so I found that
particularly funny what's the message
you're sending about white voice and are
you getting grief for even talking about
well here's the thing how Danny Glover's
character explains it in the thing is
that there is no real white voice and
everything we're doing as a performance
and that in the movie the white voice
that they use is this sort of mythical
thing that says everything's okay yes
and and that's like the performance of
whiteness for some folks is like even
though I'm making twenty two thousand a
year I'm a middle-class you know and and
so it's it's almost the the opposite of
the racist black tropes that we see up
which is like oh you know poverty is
because you know all these people
color our you know whatever savage but
it started because you're an you were a
telemarketer years ago oh yeah what did
you draw from that I'd like to hear the
pity I said in my cubicle and vowed
revenge and so this is part of it you
know I I was doing telephone raising
which was and and I was actually raising
money for the LA mission from the Bay
Area calling to Orange County which is a
very conservative neighborhood so I'll
be like hey how are you doing we're just
taking the survey making sure did you
suffer any of the break-ins today oh so
your car is okay okay
because actually I'm calling from the
Los Angeles mission and we have a new
plan to stop all of that what we're
doing is we want to get all the poor
people we want to take all the homeless
people from your neighborhood and move
them to downtown Los Angeles and so we
need help because we're gonna house them
there clothe them give them jobs I mean
I felt okay about it because I was
raising money for a homeless mission but
I also felt terrible yeah I'll ask this
question in my white voice let me ask
you did you you talked about nursing
this grievance while you were in
telemarketing but I mean you had this
script took a little while to get
through the gatekeepers and all that
talk about that process I finished
writing it in 2012 we published it as
its own paperback book in 2014 through
McSweeney's and then I went to the
Sundance labs and 20 writers lab in 2015
and Sunday as director's lab in 2016 and
we shot it last year so it's been six or
seven years of we're gonna start
shooting in three months from now you
ever worried you ever think about giving
up no because I basically you know I
painted myself into a corner where I had
no choice but to make good on the lie
that I was selling which was that we're
gonna shoot a movie you know sure dark
comedy but there really is a very
important message in that movie oh yeah
I mean I think there's an optimism that
comes through this movie that even
though the world is messed up yeah that
there is a way to change it that there's
that we there's an analysis that shows
shows that the people can do things like
withhold their labor and and and you
know take hold of things and there's an
optimism that comes from that or
shocking twists and turns in the movie
that's all I'll say you you don't want
to give it away you want people to have
the experience yeah this is this is a
movie that you will not be able to guess
what's happening next from second to
second I mean that lead it well alright
boots Riley didn't give up and it's
paying off yes sorry to bother you is in
theaters now